first time I told my wife that I love
her I might have had a little too much
tequila it's a Tale As Old As Time boy
gets a little tipsy on tequila and drops
the L word on his girlfriend and that's
exactly how Ashton Kutcher first told
Mila Kunis he loved her I mean how do
you not love him right the actor made
the confession on his new workout series
our future selves during a chat with his
guest Kenny Chesney the first time I
told my wife that I love her was while
listening to you and tequila I might
have had a little too much to Kiva I
should have drunk at her house at like
two in the morning I just started
screaming
me crazy and I told her I love her and
she's like don't say if you don't mean
it are you gonna love me in the morning
when you wake up from this hangover and
I woke up the next morning
yeah Kenny's hit song was basically the
soundtrack of that drunken he had super
sweet moment between the lovebirds
you and tequila make me crazy
[Music]
unlike poison in my blood well I have no
idea that me and Grace Potter was such a
a part of the really intimate detail for
you and your wife you you and Grace
Potter brought it home these are
fundamental moments of my life of course
Mila and Ashton met back on the set of
That 70s Show
you want to have my children well yeah
I mean if you get rich and don't lose
your hair because I love you
I love you too and tied the knot in
2015. I have a really great husband I
really do ever since the two have been
all out couple goals you know we're home
bodies like we do a lot of sitting on
the porch yeah when ET caught up with a
Vengeance star in June he gave us all
the feels talking about his real life
leading lady who had just been named one
of Time Magazine's most influential
people she might be of 100 for time but
she's up number one for me the couple
share two kids seven-year-old daughter
Wyatt and five-year-old son Dimitri
every night we high-five each other and
we're like we did it and we're still in
love like it's a you high five when you
still like each other and you still like
your kid at the end of the night and
last year Mila told DT how they juggle
their careers and kids
tag team like right I'll tell you we
never work at the same time
and um and I only or we only shoot on
location during summer breaks and then
the rest of the time we shoot at home
and their careers are colliding again
Mila and Ashton are headed back to their
That 70s Show routes with Netflix 90s
themed reboot which will feature their
characters all grown up with a kid did
it like freak your head a little bit
when you said okay I'm going back to do
this and now I'm married to this man
let me tell you first and foremost my
child without giving too much away in
this show is way too old to be my child
so I was like what what are we like teen
pair like
so okay I was like whatever so first of
all my kids way too old I want everybody
to know not possible
um it's very good it's great in fact and
I think that anyone that's never watched
70s that was a fan loved it I think
would be very very very very happy with
how they the inciting incident of this
of the whole series
[Music]